Die Schwerelosigkeit im Weltraum hat massive
Auswirkungen auf unser Gehirn.
Das ist das Ergebnis einer neuen Studie.
Und damit ist auch endlich geklärt warum
ein längerer Aufenthalt im Weltall, das Sehvermögen
deutlich beeinträchtigt.
Sind längere Reisen im Weltraum also unmöglich?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Wissenschafts-Videos, abonniert
den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich
Willkommen
Der Aufenthalt im Weltraum ist eine Tortur.
Er greift die Gesundheit des Menschen an allen
Ecken und Ende an und es ist fraglich, ob
der Mensch überhaupt einen längeren Aufenthalt
im Weltraum überleben würde.
Und eine neue Studie zu Veränderungen im
Gehirn nährt diese Erkenntnis.
Grundsätzlich fängt das Problem schon mit
der generellen Degeneration an.
Pro Monat verlieren Menschen im Weltraum 1,5
Prozent ihrer Knochenmasse.
Und Training, wie es Alexander Gerst absolviert
hat, um diese Degeneration zu verlangsamen,
hat einen extrem unangenehmen Nebeneffekt:
Fieber.
Der Körper von Weltraumfahrern liegt im Ruhezustand
rund ein Grad über dem Normalwert, der hier
auf der Erde gilt.
Körper werden im Weltraum über etwa 2,5
Monate lang immer wärmer.
Dann etwa pendelt sich die Temperatur bei
etwa 38 Grad ein.
Und das könnte fatale Folgen haben.
Messungen zeigen, dass die Körpertemperatur
der Astronauten und Astronautinnen sogar oft
auf mehr als 40 Grad ansteigt.
Eine Studie geht davon aus, dass dieses ständige
Weltraumfieber von den Umständen dort herbeigeführt
werden.
Der Körper kann in der Schwerelosigkeit nur
schwer seine überschüssige Hitze loswerden.
Und selbst wenn: Dieser verdampft weniger
als auf der Erde und wird so schlechter abtransportiert.
Und das ist nur ein Aspekt: Auch die Sehfähigkeit
nimmt im Weltall ab.
Das ist fatal. 70% der Astronauten und Astronautinnen
über 50, die ein halbes Jahr auf der ISS
waren klagen über Sehprobleme.
Brillen mussten nach dem Aufenthalt angepasst
werden und wer kein Brille hatte, bekam jetzt
eine.
Und jetzt sagt eine neue Studie, die Ursache
dafür ist fatal.
Bei der Studie wurden elf Raumfahrer und -Fahrerinnen
untersucht.
Sie waren zwischen 2014 und 2018 für einige
Zeit an Bord der Internationalen Raumstation
ISS.
Vor dem Aufenthalt im All wurde ein Hirnscan
gemacht, 10 Tage nach der Rückkehr und sieben
Monate später.
Als Vergleich gab es noch Hirnscans von Menschen,
die die Erde nicht verlassen hatten.
Die Ergebnisse sind ehrlich gesagt ernüchternd.
Der Aufenthalt auf der ISS hatte massive Auswirkungen
auf das Gehirn.
Die Hirnventrikel, Hohlräume im Gehrin, die
mit Wasser gefüllt sind, vergrößerten sich
im Schnitt um 12 Prozent.
Bei den Seitenventrikeln waren es sogar 13
Prozent.
Und hier konnte ein Zusammenhang zwischen
dieser Vergrößerung und der Verschlechterung
des Sehvermögens nachgewiesen werden.
Das ist natürlich fatal.
Zum einen ist es natürlich bedenklich, dass
die Gesundheit nach einem Aufenthalt im All
nachhaltig beeinträchtigt wird und zudem
ist die Frage: Was passiert bei längeren
Aufenthalten, wie einem Flug zum Mars?
Dehnen sich die Ventrikel weiter aus?
Welche weiteren Schäden richten sie dann
an?
Beim aktuellen Stand ist es ein kaum zu kalkulierenden
Risiko.
Eine Reise zum Mars könnte man nicht riskieren.
Die Besatzung könnte währenddessen solche
Schäden erleiden, dass sie nicht mehr in
der Lage wäre die Mission zu Ende zu bringen.
Eien absolute Katastrophe.
Einen Trost gibt es allerdings.
Diese Ausdehnung der Ventrikel geht auf der
Erde scheinbar langsam wieder zurück.
Nach sieben Monaten auf dem Boden war die
Ausdehnung wieder um die Hälfte zurückgegangen.
Die Gesundheit im Weltraum scheint ein wirklich
komplexes Problem zu sein.
Nach dem jetzigen Stand könnte sie längere
Raumflüge generell verhindern.
Für eine Marsmission müssten wir dieses
Problem und auch die anderen Herausforderungen
unbedingt lösen, damit die Reise nicht in
einer Katastrophe endet.
Wie Einsteins Gehirn gestohlen wurde - eine
absolut unglaubliche Story - anklicken, anschauen
und AstroComics Tv abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!